so
maybe like taking a little step back
from your perspective
not from the low not from the beautiful
hypograph wolfram physics model
perspective but
from the perspective of 20th century
physics what is
general relativity what is quantum
mechanics how do you think about these
two
theories from the context of the theory
of everything
like it's just even definitions yeah
yeah right so i mean
you know a little bit of history of
physics right so so i mean the the
you know okay very very quick history
yes
right so so i mean you know physics you
know in ancient greek times
people basically said we can just figure
out how the world works
as you know we're philosophers we're
going to figure out how the world works
you know some philosophers thought they
were atoms some philosophers thought
there were
you know continuous flows of things
people had different ideas about how the
world works
and they tried to just say we're going
to construct this idea of how the world
works
they didn't really have sort of notions
of doing experiments and so on quite the
same way
as developed later so that was sort of
an early tradition for thinking about
sort of models of the world then by the
time of 1600s time of galileo and then
newton
sort of the big the big idea there was
you know you know title of newton's book
you know princepi mathematica
mathematical principles of natural
philosophy
we can use mathematics to understand
natural philosophy to understand
things about the way the world works and
so that then
led to this kind of idea that you know
we can write down a mathematical
equation
and have that represent how the world
works so newton's one of his most famous
ones is
his universal law of gravity inverse
square law of gravity
that allowed him to compute all sorts of
features of of the planets and so on
although
some of them he got wrong and it was
took another hundred years for people to
actually be able to do the math
uh to the level that was needed but but
um but so that that had been
this sort of tradition was we write down
these mathematical equations we don't
really know where these equations come
from
we write them down then we figure out we
work out the consequences and we say yes
that agrees with what we actually
observe
in astronomy or something like this so
that tradition continued
and um then the first of these two sort
of great 20th century
uh innovations was uh well the history
is actually a little bit more
complicated but let's
let's say that the the um the the the
there were two quantum mechanics and
general relativity quantum mechanics
kind of 1900 was kind of the very early
uh stuff done by planck that led to
the idea of photons particles of light
um but
let's let's take general relativity
first one one feature of the story is
that special relativity thing einstein
invented in 1905
was something which surprisingly was a
kind of
logically invented theory it was not a
theory where
it was something where given these ideas
that were sort of axiomatically thought
to be true about the world
it followed that such and such a thing
would be the case
it was a little bit different from the
the kind of methodological structure of
some
of some existing theories in more in the
more recent times or it's just been we
write down an equation and we find out
that it works
so what happened there so there's some
reasoning about
the light the basic idea was the you
know the speed
of light is appears to be constant
uh you know even if you're traveling
very fast you shine a flashlight
the light will come out even if you're
going at half the speed of light
the light doesn't come out of your
flashlight at one and a half times the
speed of light
it's still just the speed of light and
to make that work
you have to change your view of how
space and time work
um to be able to account for the fact
that when you're going faster it appears
that you know
length is foreshortened and time is
dilated and things like this and that's
special relativity that's special
relativity
so then einstein went on with sort of
vaguely similar kinds of thinking 1915
invented general relativity which is the
theory of gravity
and the basic point of general
relativity is
is it's a theory that says when there is
mass
in space space is curved and what does
that mean
you know you you usually you think of
what's the shortest distance between two
points like you know ordinarily and
on a plane in space it's a straight line
you know
photons light goes in straight lines
well then the question is is if if you
have
a curved surface a straight line is no
longer straight
on the surface of the earth the shortest
distance between two points is a great
circle it's a circle
um it's uh so you know einstein's
observation was maybe the physical
uh structure of space is such that space
is curved
so the shortest distance between two
points the
the path the straight line in quotes
won't be straight anymore and in
particular
if a if a photon is is you know
traveling near
near the sun or something or if a
particle is going something is traveling
near the sun
maybe the shortest path will be one that
is
is uh is something which looks curved to
us because it seems curved to us because
space has been deformed by the presence
of mass associated with that that
massive object so so the kind of the
idea uh
there is um think of the structure of
space as being a dynamical changing
kind of thing but then what einstein did
was he wrote down these differential
equations
that basically represented the curvature
of space and its response to the
presence of mass and energy
and that all ultimately is connected to
the force of gravity which is one of the
forces that
seems to based on a strength operate on
a different scale than some of the other
forces so it operates in a scale
that's very large what happens there is
is just
this this curvature of space which
causes
you know the paths of objects to be
deflected that's what gravity does
it causes the positive objects to be
deflected and this is an
explanation for gravity so to speak and
the surprises
that from 1915 until today everything
that we've measured about gravity
precisely agrees with general ultimately
and that's um
uh and that you know it wasn't clear
black holes were sort of a predictable
actually the expansion of the universe
was an early potential prediction
although einstein tried to sort of patch
up his equations to make it not cause
the universe to expand
because it was kind of so obvious the
universe wasn't expanding
and you know turns out it was expanding
and he should have just trusted the
equations and that's a lesson for
for those of us um interested in making
fundamental theories of physics is
you should trust your theory and not try
and patch it because of something that
you think might be the case that
um uh that might turn out not to be the
case
even if the theory says something crazy
is happening
yeah right like the universe like the
universe is expanding right which is
but but um but you know then it took
until the 1940s probably even really
into the 1960s until people understood
that black holes were a consequence
of of general relativity and so on but
that's um
you know the big surprise has been that
so far
this theory of gravity has perfectly
agreed with you know these collisions of
black holes seen by the gravitational
waves
you know it all just works so that's
been kind of one pillar
of the story of physics it's
mathematically complicated to work out
the consequences of general relativity
but it's not there's there's no i mean
and and
and some things are kind of squiggly and
complicated like people believe you know
energy is conserved okay well energy
conservation doesn't really work in
general activity in the same way as it
ordinarily does and it's all
a big mathematical story of how you
actually nail down
something that is definitive that you
can talk about and not specific to the
you know reference frames you're
operating in and so on and so on and so
on but fundamentally general relativity
is a straight shot in the sense that you
have this theory you work out its
consequences
and that that theory is useful in terms
of
basic science and trying to understand
the way black holes work the way the
creation of galaxies work
sort of all these kind of cosmological
things understanding what happened
like you said at the big bang yeah like
all those kinds of
well no not at the big bang actually
right but uh
well features of the expansion of the
universe yes i mean and there are
there are lots of details where we don't
quite know how it's working you know is
there
you know where's the dark matter is
there dark energy you know et cetera et
cetera et cetera but
but fundamentally the the you know the
testable features of general relativity
it all works very beautifully
and it's it's in a sense it is
mathematically sophisticated but it is
not conceptually hard to understand in
some sense
you